de difficultés demande un rapport ben
oui mais il faudrait quand même que l'on
s'interroge sur la chaîne hiérarchique
le commandement qui débouche sur ce type
de situation moi je ne crois pas que les
hommes les femmes les policiers eux
mêmes soit par vocation des brutes
épaisses loin s'en faut et eux-mêmes
sont confrontés à des difficultés on le
sait dans certains quartiers tout agent
public doit être protégé dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions pour que son autorité
justement soit accepté par la population
donc je crois qu'il ya un véritable
problème de c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
ça fait un moment que ça dure quand même
ces difficultés et je pense qu'il ya une
chaîne de commandement une hiérarchie
des des attitudes politiques qui
devraient être
modifier de manière franche tout agent
public doit être protégé dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions vous nous offrez une
transition tout parfaite par rapport à
l'actualité du jour vous savez qu'à
l'assemblée nationale et à l'examen du
texte du projet de loi sur la sécurité
globale dont le fameux article 23 qui
concerne les encadrent 24 pardon qui
concerne l'encadrement des images de
policiers ou de gendarmes en cours
d'intervention prête à polémique
là on voit qu'on a un ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même qui se dit choqué
par des images de deux policiers en
cours d'intervention qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce cette polémique là est ce
fameux article 24 hills qu'il faut
protéger les policiers les gendarmes
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions sur
les images diffusées ou 7 cet article de
loi va bien trop loin
vous savez le syndicat unité sgp police
fo et premier syndicat dans la police et
la première des questions qu'ils posent
depuis très longtemps c'est les
conditions les moyens de l'exercice de
leur mission les la politique du chiffre
le fait que là encore une fois les
ordres notamment dans le cadre des
manifestations sont pas toujours adaptés
et mettre les policiers eux mêmes en
difficulté
évidemment tout agent public doit être
protégé notamment du risque de la
vindicte sur les réseaux sociaux
le professeur samuel bhatti a été
assassiné dans ces conditions la suite
de cela on sait que y compris des
policiers peuvent être mis en difficulté
pour le propre intégrité
pour autant ça ne doit jamais mettre en
cause les principes et droits
fondamentaux les garanties démocratiques
la liberté de la presse et c'est là que
le bât blesse c'est un vrai sujet il ya
un vrai succès pas la bonne solution
pour non c'est pas la bonne solution
surtout il y à il ya une attitude
politicienne on veut montrer que
on sait faire de l'ordre de l'autorité
mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait en
démocratie en république il faut que le
débat ait lieu qu'on prenne le temps de
la concertation qu'on ne se trompe pas y
compris dans les conséquences parce que
si à l'arrivée ce sont les principes
fondamentaux le droit de l'état de droit
qui est mis en péril
eh bien les frais sera contraire il a lu
grosse réaction
même dans l'est dans la nouvelle version
votée par l'assemblée le gouvernement se
trompe sur 7 ha bah il ya une
précipitation on prend une proposition
de loi a déjà c'est la mécanique une
procédure accélérée c'est à dire que on
raccourcit les ports ses possibilités de
débats de contradictions la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme
fo en est partie prenante pointent du
doigt le fait que à maintes reprise est
là encore elle n'a pas été consulté a
priori y siège la plupart des
organisations en matière de droits de
l'homme
donc voilà il ya un vrai problème il
faut pas faire de politique politicienne
sur ces questions c'est dangereux on va
parler de la crise sanitaire et social à
emmanuel macron qu'est donc attendu ce
soir à 20 heures
les partenaires sociaux qui ont été
consultés hier en tout cas informez vous
allez nous dire par par jean castex de
ce qui allait se passer dans la suite de
ce confinement que vous avez dit le
premier ministre à bien ce qui vient
d'être un peu dit on ne parlera pas ce
soir de déconfinement on va parler
d'adaptation du confinement de
desserrement
des contraintes et puis en perspective
notamment des fêtes de fin d'année tous
les regards sont tournés attendent la
situation des commerces et notamment du
commerce de proximité en perspective
justement des achats potentiels en
perspective des fêtes de fin d'année il
vous autour du 1er décembre alors la
question elle est ce qu on démarre un
petit peu avant c'est à dire ce week end
ou pas on n'a pas eu de précisions hier
l'idée étant d'éviter le rush qui serait
complètement contre-productif
regardez la situation sanitaire on a
compris que la l'attention sur le plan
sanitaire elle demeurait quand même
forte y compris dans certaines régions
le taux d'occupation et dépasse les 100
% des lits ouverts régulièrement en
réanimation par des patients qu'aux vide
donc voilà on a compris que les choses
sont claires de la part du prêt mines et
sur ce qu'elle annonce emmanuel macron
ce soit non pas plus que ce que je viens
de vous dire l'idée elle est
effectivement un desserrement des
contraintes une adaptation du
confinement
et puis évidemment on a quand même
évoqué cette situation commerce des
employeurs en pointer du doigt cette
recette questions à ce sujet moi j'ai
rappelé on a beaucoup parlé du commerce
de proximité des petites entreprises des
travailleurs indépendants ou des petits
patrons des petits employeurs il y a
beaucoup de salariés et les salariés
n'oublions pas que en activité partielle
on n'est pas à 100 % de la rémunération
est donc si on n'est pas au smic que
j'allais dire il n'y a que quand on a la
chance mais je peux pas dire ça comme ça
d'être au smic on est à 100 % sinon dès
que vous êtes un peu au dessus vous
perdez de la rémunération et les fêtes
de fin d'année elles vont difficile
parce que les fins de mois sont
difficiles pour tous ses salariés sans
compter le secteur café restaurant qui
ne va pas réouvrir il ya une forte
interrogation une forte inquiétude pour
tous les salariés saisonniers qui
enchaîne les petits contrats courts en
perspective de la saison d'hiver dans
tout le secteur touristique
donc là il ya une angoisse forte pour
beaucoup beaucoup de salariés qui sont
en activité partielle depuis pour
certains plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois donc
ouah d'achat est très largement entamée
et puis il ya une angoisse maintenant
sur comment on va sortir de là est ce qu
on aura toujours notre emploi donc
évidemment dans ces circonstances quand
on a des annonces comme celle de danone
ou hier c'est infernal dans des réunions
comme celle ci quand vous rencontrez le
premier ministre quand vous dites que
vous venez de nous dire là sur le
plateau vous avez le sentiment d'être
écoutés ou ce sont juste des infos des
réunions où on vous délivre de
l'information qui descend et ce qui est
un vrai dialogue
est-ce qu'il n'écoute de l'exécutif par
rapport au corps intermédiaires de
manière générale on a le sentiment que
l'exécutif écoute mais n'entend pas
forcément ce que l'on veut lui faire
y a pas eu de progrès il n'y a pas eu de
progrès en la matière depuis le début du
quinquennat
ben je parlais des saisonniers ça
renvoie immédiatement la situation des
plus précaires la réforme de l'assurance
chômage le gouvernement a dû reporté à
trois reprises sa réforme il y a été en
quelque sorte contraint les cinq
confédérations syndicales s'y était
opposé en juin 2019 les cinq
confédérations syndicales ont écrit au
premier ministre il y a de cela trois
semaines pour lui dire mettez fin à ces
tergiversations
on abandonne définitivement cette
réforme elle est reportée jusqu'au mois
d'avril mais insuffisamment sur les
droits au rechargement ce qui met en
péril est en difficulté grande tous les
petits contrats et contraint pékin on
parle de l'augmentation de la pauvreté
mais il ya beaucoup de ses salariés qui
vont basculer dans cette situation de
pauvreté faute de pouvoir recharger
leurs droits et là on voit bien que le
gouvernement tergiverse
on sent bien les rappels et bien
finalement quand même de la part du
gouvernement oui les formes de
l'assurance notamment sur le
rechargement des droits c'est pas
suffisant plat non parce que leur chance
et c'est justement le on a obtenu que la
réforme soit reportée jusqu'au 1er avril
et qu'on revienne aux dispositions en
attendant de la convention que nous
avions négocié je le rappelle c'est une
convention que nous avions négocié qui
serait en vigueur jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 si le gouvernement n'avait
pas interféré dans l'assurance chômage
et nous aurions sans doute proposé de
proroger d'une année 7
convention mais une des dispositions n'a
pas été rétablie exactement c'est celle
du rechargement
là où dans la convention précédente ont
rechargé ses droits dès qu'on
retravaille est un mois il faut quatre
mois et en ce moment avec des périodes
raccourci de saison d'été de saison
d'hiver
eh bien vous n'arrivez pas à faire le
joint et tous les petits contrats bien
se retrouve on a hurlé les projections
de l'unedic
c'est près de 500 mille salariés qui se
trouvent en difficultés pour recharger
leurs droits ou pour ouvrir leurs droits
à l'assurance chômage
avec la réforme de 2019 on va revenir
sur sur cette cette crise sociale vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les
licenciements chez chez danone ya
d'autres grandes entreprises dans
lesquelles on parle de départs
volontaires ou d'eau ou de plan je pense
notamment à total et d'autre alors qu'on
est dans un contexte où l'état aide
massivement l'industrie le commerce
l'économie en injectant beaucoup
d'argent sans finalement 102 sans
condition particulière affectés à ces
différentes aides on arrive à une espèce
de paradoxes où vous avez des
entreprises qui touchent massivement des
aides mais qui ont des pratiques
sociales qui correspondent pas forcément
qu'est-ce qu'on a ratés en la matière
abbas qu'on a ratées c'est ce qu'on dit
depuis longtemps moi je l'avais souvent
évoquées notamment dans le contexte du
débat sur les retraites puisque on nous
disait que les retraites c'était 320
milliards d'euros chaque année 14 points
de pib que les aides publiques aux
entreprises c'est près de 140 milliards
d'euros chaque année et ça c'était le
ministre à l'époque des comptes publics
monsieur darmana qu'il l'avait évalué au
bas mot 140 milliards d'euros chaque
année sans conditions sans contrôle sans
sanction évidemment ce qui s'est produit
à bridgestone ce qui se produit par
exemple avec danone qui a bénéficié
dette publique notamment
comme toutes les entreprises le cic eux
mais y compris récemment de l'activité
partielle qui a versé dans le même temps
à plus de 1 milliard à près de 1
milliard 500 millions d'euros de
dividendes aux actionnaires
annonce des suppressions d'emplois avec
comme argument favoriser la rentabilité
et rassurer les actionnaires c'est
exactement le discours qu'avait tenus
bridgestone il y a deux semaines quand
il a définitivement dit qu'il renonçait
au site de béthune pour disait-il aux
salariés améliorer la rentabilité de ses
opérations en europe
donc les salariés les emplois sont
considérés comme la variable
d'ajustement
une marchandise comme une autre ce qui
est absolument inacceptable et qu'est-ce
qu'on se prenne avec les verriers bruno
le maire il peut pas empêcher ces
entreprises de verser des dividendes à
leurs actionnaires qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire par la force des choses si vous ne
mettez pas de conditions à l'octroi des
aides publiques ya des aides publiques
de l'état et les aides publiques que met
en place les collectivités locales pour
favoriser l'implantation ou là la
pérennité de telle ou telle activité sur
le bassin d'emploi
et si vous n'y mettez pas de conditions
si vous n'y mettez pas ensuite de
contrôle et de sanction a priori et bien
le moment venu vous vous trouvez démunis
c'est exactement la situation dans
laquelle se trouve l'état par exemple à
bridgestone qui nous dit qu'il a fait
son maximum et qu'il se trouve dans la
situation aux bridgestone vient de lui
dire que ben non on ferme le site de
béthune et ben on va chercher un
repreneur on va chercher une façon ou
une autre de trouver une poursuite mais
on sait que on y perdra des emplois et
je le redis ces entreprises notamment
multinationales ce qui est choquant avec
danone sais qu'elle m'aime à utiliser
l'appellation d'entreprise a mission qui
est censé avoir d'autre objectif que de
favoriser l'actionnariat et bien ces
entreprises sont très agiles sont treize
habile pour faire leur marché sur les
aides publiques et une fois qu'elles
sont consommés ici aller en chercher une
autre ailleurs ailleurs sur dans une
autre région en france ou plus souvent
ailleurs en europe ou plus loin et ça
c'est inacceptable il faut que à être
public puisqu'on parle de plan de
relance
eh bien il faut que le gouvernement soit
beaucoup plus exigeant beaucoup plus
strictes quant à l'octroi des aides
publiques et nous ne l'avons fait sur le
prêt garanti
par l'état 1 bruno le maire en dix ans
qui signera pas de prêts garantis par
l'état ou willy caderby direct pour vous
il faut il aller il faut élargir
il faut bien sûr même doute toute forme
dead les allégements de cotisations
notamment qui pénalise les recettes on
va parler à nouveau de l' équilibre des
systèmes de protection sociale et des
retraites
les systèmes de protection sociale y
pâtissent d'une insuffisance de recettes
et donc dès que vous faites des
allégements de cotisations qui sont dits
pour favoriser l'emploi en règle
générale ce sont des êtres public quand
vous faites de l'activité passée de
longue durée n'oubliez pas on parlait de
l'unedic qui est confronté à un déficit
important l'unedic prend en charge un
tiers pour un tiers l'activité partielle
donc à chaque fois vous mettez de l'aide
publique il faut interdire tout
versement de dividendes de interdire
tout licenciement sec toute suppression
d'emplois contre at on l'a obtenu à
airbus
on l'a obtenue récemment arnaud et ça
démontre qu'on peut le faire par la
négociation mais on ne l'obtient pas
partout malheureusement
j'ajoute quand même que quand il ya des
plans de départs volontaires dans les
circonstances actuelles
c'est autant d'emplois en moins or hier
ce qu'on a eu comme information de la
part de la ministre du travail
c'est que ont été recensés d'ores et
déjà cette année sept plus de 700 pse et
ça représente plus de 70 mille
suppressions d'emplois d'ores et déjà
donc pour l'année 2020 pour l'année 2020
c'est plus que le double voire le triple
en suppressions d'emplois de ce qui
avait été constaté sur l'année 2019 donc
on voit bien que le delta le déficit
d'emploi il est massif
on a tout lieu de s'inquiéter sur la
sortie compris début 2000 21 si on finit
par sortir de cette crise sanitaire
on risque de laisser quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises de petite entreprise sur
le carreau autant de salariés sur le
carreau
donc je pense que il faut vraiment
mettre le paquet et moi je le redis dans
le plan de relance la question des
emplois de ce qu'on a appelé la deuxième
ligne doit être partie intégrante de la
relance il faut qu'on appuie la relance
en matière d'emploi surtout ces emplois
qu'on avait qualifié d'essentiel tous
les emplois sont essentiels mais cela en
particulier
services à la personne on a un gros
souci par exemple sur la déclinaison du
ségur au secteur du social et du médico
social ils n'ont pas perçu devrim cobek
beaucoup d'entre eux dit il faut mettre
le paquet si vous estimez que le
gouvernement a pas m'a pas mis
suffisamment de moyens pour faire face à
cette crise parce que les montants sont
énormes
ou alors c'est l'argent va pas mis au
bon endroit on a soutenu et heureusement
qu'on l'a fait je viens de dire on a
négocié par exemple au sein d'airbus au
sein de renault dans le cadre
mais l'autorité laeticia hallyday
l'argent public injecté pour soutenir
l'économie est énorme
oui mais en ce moment même et
heureusement parce que faudrait encore
allongée vous pensez je pense qu il
mieux gérer cet argent toute façon tant
que la crise dure et on va voir ces
discussions par exemple lierre ce qui a
été dit c'est qu'on allait prolonger
du côté du gouvernement l'activité
partielle jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2012
enfin le pas l'activité partielle le
télétravail travail et domicile les
années de la demie devant excusez moi
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 et que
l'activité partielle les modalités de
prise en charge de l'activité partielle
et être en validité jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 et qu'il allait falloir
qu'on regarde comment on va ajuster en
fonction de ce que seront les
indicateurs épidémiologique la période
de début de l'année 2000 21 mai si
effectivement on est toujours sous
tension il faut absolument préserver des
emplois donc si il faut il froid
prolonger les aides pour préserver les
emplois bien justement vous parlez du
télétravail verrier on va terminer là
dessus parce qu'il y avait une réunion
hier entre les partenaires sociaux sur
cette question du télétravail puisque il
est question de trouver un accord
national entre partenaires sociaux sur
ce télétravail à huit heures de
négociations hier la réunion est
interrompu et reprend ce matin qu'est ce
qui bloque ce qui bloque depuis le début
les employeurs ils sont entrés à
reculons en rechignant les employeurs se
sont très largement adapté au fait que
l'on renvoie systématiquement la
négociation au niveau local voire au gré
à gré c'est à des points bloquants pour
nous par exemple dans cette négociation
c'est que nous pensons que le
télétravail doit être mis en place dans
les entreprises en passant par une
négociation à tout le moins au niveau de
l'entreprise et c'est ce que nous
voudrions voir inscrit de manière
prescriptive les employeurs ne veulent
pas de prescriptif dans l'accord
national interprofessionnel
parce que les ordonnances travail de
2017 ont mis en place la possibilité de
mettre du télétravail et de gré à gré
sans formalisme c'est à dire sans
avenant au contrat de travail
ça ça n'est pas acceptable il faut qu'on
revienne là-dessus donc ce qui bloque
c'est que les employeurs voilà se sont
habitués à cela ils ne veulent pas ils
nous l'ont dit d'accord normatif ou
prescriptif donc on a un texte à deux
contraintes
pas de contrainte voilà de l'accès au
très haut niveau national
interprofessionnel
évidemment pour qu'on négocie un accord
qui vaille la peine
il en faut un peu donc les choses ont
avancé on a réussi à les amener en
discute et on a réussi à ce qu'on ouvre
une négociation véritablement on a
réussi à avoir un texte mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on est au milieu du gué
mais il ya seulement le côté travailleur
qui a franchi un pas on s'est mis au
milieu du gué mais les employeurs ils
tâtent encore l'eau pour voir si elle
n'est pas trop chaude et nous confère à
ce moment que ça soit lancement mais on
n'est pas encore à un niveau qui
permette d'aller à un accord donc mais
clairement vous nous dites s'il n'y a
pas de texte contraignant n'y aura pas
d'accord pour vous c'est sa as on va
voir on reprend un visa y avoir des
comptes courants à 10h30 nous on veut
donner toutes ses chances à la
négociation on tient à ce qu'on puisse
négocier y compris au niveau national
interprofessionnel
parce qu'il faut qu'on mette on voit
bien tous les salariés aujourd'hui se
retrouver à travailler à domicile dans
des conditions qui étaient mal préparées
dans des conditions qu'ils ne
maîtrisaient pas y compris en termes de
temps de travail de droit à la
déconnexion effectifs ça aussi ça fait
partie des questions qu'on veut voir
absolument inscrits dès qu'il ya
télétravail il faut qu'un accord précise
les modalités d'un droit effectif à la
déconnexion qu'on sépare bien vie privée
de la vie professionnelle quand on est
dans les circonstances du télétravail
donc il faut que les employeurs
l'entendent et nous
pense important que l'on mette tous les
salariés à égalité puisque tous les
salariés maintenant qu'ils sont
susceptibles de pouvoir télétravail et
regarde avec attention et on ne peut pas
se satisfaire d'une situation d'omar où
selon l'entreprise il ya des entreprises
on a passé des accords qu'on a nous
mêmes signes et faux dans certaines
entreprises dotées le travail
il n'y a pas de raison que tous les
salariés ne puisse pas en bénéficier de
la même façon c'est le salon protéger
les salles à s'annoncer comme une teen
négociations ça sera le cas où il y aura
forcément une autre réunion pour vous ou
pour vous ça peut être conclu
aujourd'hui moi je donne toutes les
chances à la négociation jusqu'au bout
c'est une vraie bagarre une négociation
c'est pas une discussion autour d'un
café et ce que j'espère c'est que tout
un chacun puisse en sortir la tête haute
et satisfait du résultat on va voir et
c'est la dernière histoire juste une
petite précision ce sont des
négociations que vous menez sous forme
de visioconférence qui facilite pas les
choses
vous êtes vous êtes là vous avez les
mains dans le cambouis celle
illustration par l'exemple l'été le
télétravail c'est pas simple exactement
et c'est un des points d'achoppement des
négociations
on ne veut pas ce que voudraient les
employeurs que ce soit une occasion de
favoriser la réunion des institutions
représentatives du personnel le cs eux
par visioconférence là on a un point dur
avec des employeurs par exemple merci
beaucoup merci verrier à la cérémonie ce
matin stéphane on regarde la ligne de
ouest-france trafic d'armes
les coulisses d'une enquête hors norme
hors norme c'est à la une de votre
journal ce matin merci messieurs en fait
sous tito club des terres et à la
mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
représente le club des territoires angie
acteurs engagés n'aurait transition zéro
carbone des régions vous présente le
club des territoires la presse
quotidienne régionale et les télévisions
locales vous présente le club des
territoires le club des territoires en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale les télévisions locales et les
indés radios
[Musique]